il faut avoir l'air très souvent et
d'avoir jean castex est venu à besançon
présenter le plan de l'exécutif pour
faciliter l'embauché des jeunes
le gouvernement met 6 milliards et demi
d'euros sur la table
mesure phare une aide de 4000 euros pour
les entreprises qui recrutent un jeune
en cdi ou en cdd
nous devons à tout prix favoriser
l'embauché des jeunes en réduisant
donnant des primes aux embauches pour
cette population pour les moins de 25
ans en favorisant en particulier
l'embauché des apprentis parce que
l'apprentissage ça marche très bien
après la visite d'un centre de formation
des apprentis de l'industrie jean castex
et trois de ses ministres ont pu
constater la réussite de ces cursus dans
une entreprise voisine spécialisé dans
les microtechniques
le premier ministre a d'ailleurs appelé
les salariés à devenir les premiers
promoteurs de leur formation en
alternance
sait on essaie toujours trouver du
travail assez pas seulement on le dire
et le répéter si vous vous parler aux
jeunes le tout ça vous serez plus
crédible comme moi vous écoutera plus le
premier ministre a aussi pu entendre les
inquiétudes des chefs d'entreprises
confrontées aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire notamment dans le secteur
automobile la rentrée sera compliqué
pour les chefs d'entreprises de se
positionner mal gré merci pour le pour
les aides mais on veut bien prendre des
jeunes et les former si on a du travail
et ça c'est le point de préoccupation
aujourd'hui de l'ensemble des
entrepreneurs de la région et d'ailleurs
avec son plan daide l'exécutif espère
susciter 450 mille embauches de jeunes
et limiter ainsi la crise économique et
sociale havanization en tout cas de